you know what was the best lib thing
[Music]
you got plenty to to throw you can't
make through laughs make them gag
[Music]
[Applause]
my own
[Applause]
hands-down the most legendary lipstick
and think of all time on drag races
maybe in Brooklyn it was fun to do and
it was fun to watch the many mayor many
layers of outfit and wigs that kept us
on the edge of our seats
[Music]
everyone loves that everyone knows
[Music]
[Applause]
Edie and Brooke turned it out that's
what they call flexibility I've heard
about it sorry not sorry that was the
best lip-syncing drag race herstory girl
obviously everyone's gonna say Evie I'm
Brooklyn but I really enjoyed um Ariel
Versace falling on our hands
really come on Little Miss slip and
slide and then pick one of Mines you
know one two three four you got plenty
to chew throw
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what was the best lib thing no
scrub
[Music]
it was mad I was horrible I was sitting
at where everyone said that meant me I
was just as shocked as America oh my god
the six-way listing was shocking
that was crazy I'm glad I wasn't on that
the fix garlic sink was the best iconic
moment of darkness history ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]